hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast enhancing checkpoint blockade
in lymphoma with insight to vaccination
I am to do or collaborates and I'll be
your moderator for today's event today's
webcast is presented by labyrinth calm
the leading social media site for
science professional and sponsored by
fluid I'm fluid I'm develops
manufactures and markets life science
analytical and preparatory systems for
markets such as math cytometry
high-throughput genomics and single-cell
genomics we sell to reading academic
institutions clinical research
laboratories and pharmaceutical
biotechnology and agricultural
biotechnology companies worldwide our
systems are based on proprietary
microfluidics and multi-parameter mass
spectrometry technology and are designed
to significantly simplify experimental
work flow increase throughput and reduce
costs while providing excellent data
quality pluton products are provided for
research use only not for use in
diagnostic procedures to learn more
about fluid I'm please visit www salud
I'm calm before we start there are a few
instructions we want to hear from you
during this interactive broadcast so
please ask questions or leave us a
comment answer is welcome to and you can
do this by hitting the green Q&A button
at the lower left of the presentation
window and typing in your comments and
questions we'll try to get to as many as
we can and we'll follow up if we don't
have time today want a better look you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
can't hear or see this presentation
properly let us know by clicking on the
support button on the top right or use
the Q&A button we'll make sure we try to
resolve any issues now let's get right
to today's presenters we are proud to
welcome Michelle Poulin PhD and Joshua
Brody MD doctor Poulin earned her
bachelor's degree from Smith College and
her PhD in immunology from the
University of Colorado Denver after
completing a postdoctoral fellowship at
national jewish health in 2003 she
joined ed Biosciences as an instructor
in the crust
our education department in 2012 dr.
Poulin joined DVF sciences as a field
application scientist and became manager
of the North American field application
scientist team shortly after DBS was
acquired by fluid I'm in 2014 dr. Brody
is an assistant professor in hematology
and medical oncology and the director of
the lymphoma immunotherapy program at
the Icahn School of Medicine finally in
New York City is also a member of the
lymphoma research foundation's mental
cell lymphoma consortium in a lymphoma
research foundation career development
award grant recipient dr. Brody received
his MD from State University of New York
stony brook school of medicine and his
bachelor's degree in molecular and
cellular biology from Harvard University
he completed his residency in internal
medicine at yale-new Haven Hospital and
his fellowship in medical oncology at
Stanford University School of Medicine
with clinical focus in chronic lymphoid
leukemia cutaneous lymphomas follicular
lymphoma mantle cell lymphoma and
post-transplant lymphoproliferative
disorders is lab at Mount Sinai focuses
on basic and applied tumor immunology I
will now turn it over to dr. Poulin will
be giving a brief overview of the mass
spectrometry technology before dr. Brody
prison enhancing checkpoint blockade in
lymphoma with insight to vaccination
thank you Judy as Judy just mentioned I
just want to give you a short
introduction to the mass cytometry
technology as you're all well aware
biology is inherently heterogeneous and
biological systems consist of
heterogeneous cell types each of these
with diverse functions and functional
states such complexity demands the use
of high-dimensional proteomics panels
that can simultaneously measure breadth
and depth in your system of interest
with single-cell resolution mass
cytometry uniquely enables this with the
ability to look at more than 50
parameters simultaneously on millions of
cells it uniquely enables both the
discovery of new biology and
pretense of functional profiling across
a range of research areas including
basic research drug discovery and
clinical research to describe math
cytometry technology I'll explain the
five elements of math cytometry firstly
is metals we use metals as our tags and
we have more than 50 high purity metal
isotopic tags to be used because of
their high purity we see minimal
background from signal overlap between
these tags and because these metals do
not occur naturally in biological
systems we do not get background from
endogenous cellular components then we
build panels we can build large
dimensional panels using our max par
metal conjugated antibodies there are
more than 600 pre conjugated antibodies
in our catalog which enable both
phenotypic and functional applications
these antibodies can be purchased
individually or as part of pre optimized
panel kits in addition we sell labeling
kits in 35 different metals that allow
you to conjugate your metal of choice to
your antibodies interest and fluid I'm
also offers custom conjugation services
in addition we offer cell ID reagents
which are non antibody-based such as bar
coding intercalate errs which identify
single-cell events and cisplatin as a
dead cell indicator with these high
dimensional panels we then stain
ourselves of interest with a method very
similar to what you may already be using
for flow cytometry the st. stained cells
are then passed in a single single self
suspension into the Helios instrument
where the cells are ionized in our high
energy plasma into an ion cloud from
there the ion cloud is transmitted into
our deck
some chamber where a single detector is
able to read and identify each of these
separate tags with one Dalton resolution
our third generation math cytometry the
helios has a hundred and thirty-five
mass channels from 75 to 209 dolphins
which allows us to measure all of our
existing tags as well as those that are
developed in the future and lastly we
come to cells the helios collects
multiparametric data for large numbers
of cells per sample enabling proteomic
profiling for breakfast cell types all
in a single tube and just as a way to
conclude I wanted to show you a graph
showing the ramp of publications
utilizing math cytometry and as you'll
see over the last few years there has
been a very large ramp in these papers
showing that the technology is becoming
widely widely accepted and many new
researchers are publishing their
research that has utilized this
breakthrough technology and I'll hand it
now back over to Judy thank you dr.
bulan for that informative presentation
I will now turn it over to dr. Brody
Judy thank you so much and Michelle
thank both of you guys for the
introduction in the explanation and
thank you to everyone who's joining
throughout the country throughout the
world going to take a little time to
tell you some application of this very
advanced form of a new monitoring that
we've incorporated into a lot of our
clinical trials this first slide is just
our aspiration and a little bit of our
success we've actually had patients
doing well with novel immune therapies
that we've developed and a lot of that
is due to our ability to understand how
these immunotherapies are working our
goal here is to learn how to improve
immunotherapies for cancer overall
certainly the most famous subclass of
immunotherapy is now refer to as
checkpoint blockade these are perhaps
the greatest breakthrough in cancer
therapy in the last four decades but
still with a huge amount of room for
improvement these therapies help a lot
of people but ultimately the majority of
cancer patients still don't get benefit
we need to improve checkpoint blockade
and this approach we refer to as insight
to vaccination has been our focus this
is our institution Mount Sinai School of
Medicine in New York and this is the
concept of insight to vaccination we
started some of this work when I was
working at Stanford in California the
idea that we can make a vaccine not just
in a factory as we do with flu vaccine
and hepatitis B vaccine all of these
vaccines are conceptually a similar
thing they're just bringing together
something we want the immune system to
hate or something that is an antigen and
hopefully an immunogen and somehow Co
localizing that with something which is
immune stimulatory and some vaccines
co-localized that thing automatically a
live flu vaccine has flu influenza virus
particles which are naturally immune
stimulatory but we don't have to
co-localize the antigen and the immune
stimulant in a factory we can do it
right here at the tuner and that was the
idea here in these first trials we have
these patients with lymphoma all of
these be cell derived lymphomas this
common cancer that we see every day in
the clinic all of these lymphomas
expressed toll-like receptor nine
therefore if we co-localize at tlr9
agonist CPG we can convert those tumor
cells into antigen presenting cells they
can present some of their own antigens
and these are not professional apc's but
they can still present antigens to a
degree these tumors also have
professional apc's within them dendritic
cells unfortunately they have very few
but hopefully we could activate some of
those professional apcs as well with
co-localized tlr agonist in between
these two amateur and professional NPCs
hopefully we could activate some to
reactive t-cells those t-cells would
show that they're activated by
expressing surface markers like CD 137
by secreting antitumor cytokines like
interferon gamma and possibly those
t-cells might be doing two thousand
other things that we haven't shown you
on this picture and ultimately that's
going to be largely the purpose of why
we're including this discussion in the
context of mass cytometry because we
don't know really what to look at on
that t-cell I mentioned two things here
but there could be many many other
markers cytokines or combinations
thereof and that's why we need to be
able to look very broadly at those
potentially tumor reactive T cells but
this was the concept as we began the
insights to vaccine approach we brought
this concept into a clinical trial we
treat patients at one site one tumor
with something called mini dose
radiation and then this intratumoral
injections of this Taylor agonist called
CPG and we don't look at that site
regreses or shrinks that would really be
cheating because the radiation by itself
might just cause regression but if we
see tumors that are far away that were
not irradiated and not injected with
these if we see those tumors shrinking
for us that is a real indication of
inducing anti-tumor immunity
systemically so that is really our Rio
de news trial so the question is can we
induce systemic regressions of these
patients tumors and the answer is that
we can this was the first 15 patients
that we treated we treat a total of
sixty patients and as you see on the
right here some of these patients had
partial
or complete regressions of their tumors
and again sites far away from the site
that we injected with the with the
immune stimulant so that was extremely
gratifying for us we publish this now re
a few years ago and this is just one
picture of one of those patients you see
on the top left and i'm not a
radiologist most people on the on the
caller not radiologists but in radiology
and great hint is if you see a green
circle that's usually a bad thing and
you see this green circle around this
bulky tumor in the back of the person's
abdomen kidneys on the left and right
liver over here on the left back bone at
the bottom belly button at the top and
this green circle is a bulky tumor we
see that this patient was one of our
first patients on that trial i described
they were injected at a site far away
from this tumor a site near in England a
lymph node and after therapy you see
this tumor now is a small green circle
so almost completely regressed and
alongside this tumor regression we saw
the induction of antitumor t-cell that
will go into this simple flow cytometry
SI in great detail we basically
coculture the person's peripheral blood
t cells with a sample of their own tumor
that we obtained before therapy and we
see post vaccination the person cd8
t-cells make more interfering gamma in
response to their on tumor so these are
literally tumor reactive cd8 t-cells and
on the right side we see that these cd8
t-cells specifically in the cd45ro high
group the memory cd8 t-cell subgroup
expressed more CD 137 when they see
autologous tumor in vitro so two more
reactive t-cells correlating with this
bulky tumor melting away very gratifying
for us very good for the patient in this
case because some of these remissions
are ongoing for years but the whole
purpose here of stimulating the immune
system at the site of the tumor is to
accomplish what I'm going to call a
magical thing this thing called
cross-presentation so normally if tumor
antigens are outside of dendritic cells
or other apcs those antigens and this is
all
you know it gets back to me knology want
to win 101 it should not be news to most
of you here today these exogenous
antigens get endocytosed and they very
naturally go in through endocytic
pathways that end up in them getting
represented on class to MHC molecules
and presented to cd4 t-cells that is
good and important but ultimately not
what we think we really need in tumor
immunotherapy we think we need to
educate cd8 tumor reactive T cells so
that requires that these originally
exogenous antigens somehow and here's
the magical part magically get out of
these endosomes or other vesicles get
into the cytosol and now reprocess
through cytosolic pathways through tap
and then into MHC class 1 groove so they
can be presented on the surface to cd8
t-cells and we can induce antitumor cd8
needed immunity that whole trick this
cytosolic diversion of endocytosed
antigen is called cross-presentation and
we need to accomplish that here we think
that there are certain a pcs that are
able to induce cross-presentation and
foremost amongst those are dendritic
cells I mentioned this problem in the
old paradigm is that we had a paucity of
dendritic cells in the tumor when we
started those clinical trials there
wasn't much we could do about that but
now there is something we can do we have
access to clinical grade flip three log
in for three log and is the primary
growth and differentiation factor of
dendritic cell precursors sometimes we
call it the erythropoietin of dendritic
cells or the g-csf neupogen of dendritic
cells it can induce differentiation and
eventually proliferation of dendritic
cells and now we can bring many
dendritic cells into the tumor once they
have endocytosed some tumor antigen we
can activate those dendritic cells with
different tlr agonists well I'll mostly
talk about today is a tlr3 agonist but
we have a probably number of options
there which t la Reagan is to use as
these dendritic cells do express a
number of different toll-like receptors
so now after tlr agonism we have a bunch
of tumor antigen loaded professional
activated a pcs vendor it excels and
hopefully these can really
powerfully induce activation of tumour
reactive t-cells and as they get
activated they will proliferate and go
and do systemic anti-tumor immunity so
that is the concept we first did some
brief assessment of how this actually
can play out in preclinical modeling and
some of these animal models we use
tumors that are labeled with a fluoro
protein m cherry so we can keep track of
both the tumor cells but also any
entrant within Excel that ingest tumor
cells because they become somewhat M
sherry labeled go briefly through this
somewhat complex flow cytometric gating
strategy we use to focus on different
dendritic cell subsets I won't go into
detail here for the sake of time and at
the end of the day emphasized first just
that we can increase the number of
dendritic cells in the tumor this first
histogram here using the slip 3 ligand
intratumoral II in fact it works even a
bit better when we administer the
flitter log and into the tumor as
opposed to nearby but really either of
them work out the punchline really here
is that flits relogin can induce both
systemic and intratumoral dendritic cell
infiltration both in the tumor and in
the tumor draining lymph node as we see
here and looking at one of our earlier
math cytometric acai tov experiments to
make this point even a bit more
elegantly we're comparing here into to
merle slippery ligand on the right as
opposed to intro to merle gm-csf another
myeloid stimulating cytokine that
historically has been used in really the
vast majority of tumor immunotherapy
vaccine based trials so gm-csf is really
the historical precedent and now here we
see with slippery log and this is a
spade plot of mass cytometric data so we
are looking at really almost the entire
immune repertoire throughout this tumor
using a 34 Plex mass cytometry assay and
then we are getting on many different
subsets of dendritic cells and we've
named them here you can see on the right
PDC plasmacytes oi dendritic cells and
all the way on the right different
subsets of Milo dendritic cell cd11b
dendritic cells tlr3 expressing
dendritic cells and the color coding
here is
fold increase is actually a log fold
increase as compared to the control
which was a saline control the punchline
of the whole experiment is that you see
foot 3 induces many many fold increase I
think these were up to beyond the order
of magnitude increases in tlr3
expressing dendritic cells and also see
the 11b dendritic cells as compared to
controls and overall gm-csf had a much
milder effect on the intratumoral immune
repertoire especially on dendritic cell
subsets so we think flit 3l is very
potent have bringing dendritic cells
into the tumor and hopefully dendritic
cells that we think are good at cross
presentation because they've been
described that way and also some
actionable observations about these
dendritic cells that they express tlr3
and we should be able to activate it
with tlr3 agonist just showing some of
that same data again flow cytometry that
the cells recruited by the three are
mostly trlr three expressing but we also
have some cd11b dendritic cells as well
and when we look at what that looks like
in the tumor prior to therapy these
tumors are extremely bland they are non
inflamed we sometimes call them cold
tumors because they are not inflamed and
there's very little immune infiltrate at
all when we look at cd11c and tlr3
expression after flip 3 administration
we see massive infiltration of dendritic
cells into these tumors these red areas
are cd11c d elevenses pressing dendritic
cells and the green overlaid with red
are the tlr3 positive cd11c dendritic
cells so we can bring dendritic cells of
these subtypes into the tumor they don't
rest around the tumor periphery they
infiltrate well into the tumor and we
look even more at some other surface
markers to more rigorously tell the the
phenotype of these dendritic cells here
the x-axis are other markers of cross
presenting dendritic cells XCR one
langer and collect 9a the z axis the
color coming out at you is the fact that
most of these are highly expressed cd8
as well and more of these express those
markers than 11 be so same data shown in
a few different ways all getting towards
the purpose of
proving that these dendritic cells we
recruit should be able to cross present
tumor antigens one marker I didn't
mention to you CD 103 CD 103 has been a
big focus both in our group and in the
group of one of my mentors professor
Mary mourad and her group as well as a
few others have published the importance
of CT 103 dendritic cells in tumor
immunotherapy and other contexts this
was a paper that we published in
immunity last year shown here on the
left that CD 103 migratory dendritic
cells were really uniquely able to cross
present tumor antigens what you see here
is a CF SE plot of antitumor t-cells
just 0 T 1 and x over T cells really
proliferating but only when they are
exposed to tumor antigen in the context
of 103 positive migratory dendritic
cells and then just going all the way
over here to this tumor growth curve on
the right this was a to me amazing and
even a little bit surprising story but
it has convinced me now that as this
most famous therapy that we use in
cancer immunotherapy pbl one blockade we
see give some benefit that black curve
here as tumors growing in the
unmanipulated States a lower royal blue
curve is the benefit of anti PDL one
antibodies showing that those tumors
grow more slowly and some might actually
have tumor regression but the surprise
here is that the light blue curve shows
that that benefit of checkpoint blockade
is completely lost when we redo the
experiment in a dendritic cell depleted
mouse a bat f 3 knockout mouse which
doesn't express which doesn't create
these CD 103 cross presenting dendritic
cells so that's amazing to me we think
of checkpoint blockade as a t-cell
therapy and it is one but that t-cell
therapy relies completely on the Opera
re-cross presentation of tumor antigens
by these dendritic cells so if you want
to check point blockade to work well we
do need dendritic cells and what I'll
try to convince you today is that
perhaps the more dendritic cells the
better as long as we're getting the
right type of dendritic cells I didn't
show you CD 103 dendritic cells in that
mouse assay I described and this is some
of that same amounts of data i already
showed you showing we recruit many tlr3
dendritic cells here on the right of
this 3d plot a smaller number of cd11b
dendritic cells but in the z axis we CCD
103 and they're really very few CD 103
positive dendritic cells as I mentioned
and then translate this into our patient
clinical trials we include a radiation
so this is the non-irradiated control
group but then we were I guess gratified
to see that when we add a radiation 9
gray radiotherapy to that tumor site
many of these tlr3 positive dendritic
cells are now expressing CD 103 you know
in our belief and I think we're probably
right about this is that these we're
just call CD 103 precursor dendritic
cells as we see they were the same in
every other marker tlr3 xcr 1 etc but
only their final activation and in this
case that activation occurs after local
radiotherapy presumably releasing some
damps causes their expression of CD 103
so at the end of radiotherapy we do have
the CD 103 tlr3 positive dendritic cells
hopefully they really will be able to
cross present tumor antigens to
antitumor t-cells I'll just very quickly
go through and in vitro
cross-presentation asset that we use to
assess this we won only studied
cross-presentation not direct
presentation by a tumor cell so we have
crisper gene edited out beta 2
microglobulin from these gfp-expressing
a 20 lymphoma cells here so they cannot
present themselves they don't have beta
2 microglobulin on their surface but
they are really just a tumor source of
antigen and the antigen here is going to
be gfp because at the end of this assay
will use a very cool readout developed
by another lab neighbor of ours dr.
Brian Brown the Jedi t-cells that you
see on top which are gfp reactive cd8
t-cells so they will react hopefully to
the GFP that's starting in these tumor
cells so we have gfp containing class 1
not expressing tumor cells we cola-cola
we co culture them with dendritic cells
that
have or haven't received till our
agonist and then we assess whether those
hopefully tumor antigen loaded dendritic
cells can now cross present to these
Jedi t-cells we read out here letter C
cross presentation by those Jedi T cells
proliferating and then indeed we read
out whether these Jedi T cells can also
kill so just looking at each part of
that this is sort of the first part we
see these cd11c dendritic cells over two
hours eight hours in the day starting to
eat gfp and become gfp-positive so
that's sort of the first petri dish you
see here in the assay the second petri
dish is now we see that we're looking
here at the Jedi T cells and they start
to proliferate just moving to the bottom
right of this assay we see they
proliferate best when the feeding and
student per centum cells came from a
mouse with slit 3l and when those
dendritic cells here on the bottom right
were exposed to tlr agonist poly i see
so we see 28.8 percent of these Jedi T
cells proliferating only when the APC
was the optimal APC in terms of flip 3l
mobilization and poly IC activation so
we can load these dendritic cells with
tumor antigen we can cross present them
to cd8 t-cells and then those t-cells
can go on to kill target cells of the
last part you know this third petri dish
is now Co culturing those activated jit
cells with the normal tumor cell that
does express class 1 and does express
the GFP antigen and just to summarize
some of what so much larger assay when
we add when we don't add the Jedi T
cells on the bottom row here we see that
we have mixtures of green and red
lymphoma cells and when we do add the
Jedi T cells here on the top row we see
that those green cells are eliminated
almost completely have gone down from
fifty percent 2.7% or if we've activated
the cross priming dendritic cells with
poly I see almost completely gone these
tumor cells been two-point-three percent
and of course it only works when those
cross priming source of antigen actually
had the GFP antigen here we see a
control and
right column when there was no GFP
antigen in the cross priming and then
just one more version of the same
experiment we've enriched for a new type
of lymphoma cell which is naturally more
t-cell resistance and repeated the assay
and basically the outcome here is
looking all the way to the right we see
that only when we have poly IC activated
dendritic cells are they effectively
cross Prime now these sensitive tumor
cells have gone down to eighteen percent
instead of the sixty-two percent now
that they started with so even with
fairly resistant tumor cells these cross
primed Jedi cd8 t-cells can kill cancer
pretty well because of the effective
cross primont got from dendritic cells
so just to summarize the purpose of all
of this we basically reproduce what we
do in clinical trials with the mice to
inject 43 login into one tumor again I
already showed you that dendritic cells
are recruited to that tumor we radiate
that tumor and when we do so we see here
on the right that many more of these
dendritic cells and now absorbing the
floor of protein tumor antigen cherry
much more so after nine grey irradiation
than when there's no irradiation and now
when we activate these tumor antigen
loaded dendritic cells these nine gray
eight point nine percent and nine point
eight percent dendritic cells only
activate them with poly I see at the
tumor site we get effective anti-tumor
immunity here we see in the red curve
the triplet therapy flip three
radiotherapy and poly I see is even much
better than the doublet therapy we don't
even actually have the control group on
here which is the untreated mice their
tumors grow very quickly and those mice
are usually dead by day 16 so a lot of
benefit here at the tumor site and also
benefit on the right side of the page
here at a distant untreated tumor site
as well and of course the purpose of
this is to understand the mechanisms
enough that we can bring this to
patients and that's what we've done we
wrote an IND get the FDA's permission
brought this into a clinical trial for
patients we basically do a newer version
of what I described before I'm always
supposed to remember that we're very
lucky to get funding from the
damon runyon cancer research foundation
to allow us to do this trial and
basically the model is similar what I
showed you before we inject klit-er-el
into a tumor mini dose radiotherapy
intratumoral tlr agonist Polly I see and
again reading out progression that
distant distant tumor sites so this
trial is still ongoing but we've treated
a number of patients now in those first
few patients we do some real-time immune
monitoring so these are fine needle
aspirates of the patient's tumor that
we're treating and we see after slipped
relogin therapy the cd1 see dendritic
cells have now increased from 0% up to
six percent the zero-percent was really
something like 0.01 or something so it's
about a six hundred fold increase in
these dendritic cells in the tumor as we
see in the middle panel here those
dendritic cells don't stay there forever
we think they eventually traffic away to
the secondary lymphoid tissue so we see
they are mostly gone afterwards we see a
recruitment of CD 141 dendritic cells on
top here in the middle panel as well we
can recruit dendritic cells with
slippery log in and then with
radiotherapy we can activate those
dendritic cells so we see this blue gate
means myeloid cells that are cdat high
and PDL one low so we think of them as
activated and we see here going from
prior before therapy pretreatment to
after well it sells in the tumor and I
think we maybe pause now and we see that
those activated myeloid cells are in the
tumor we don't want to want to inflame
the tumor you know make activation of my
lord tells you where we don't want to
inflame the entire person and that's
what we see that if we look in the
person's blood at the same time whereas
on the right side here the myeloid cells
are activated in the tumor you see on
the bottom right the myeloid cells are
generally not activated in the
peripheral blood so we hopefully are
inducing to Merle inflammation but not
systemic inflammation that is our goal
so it was gratifying to see even in
these first few patients that we treated
and I was will just quickly mention here
that the black lines are the first
couple of patients overall tumor
regression and these patients are having
fifty percent forty to fifty percent
tumor regressions the blue and pink
lines are showing those pain patients
blood red blood cells and platelets
improving but let me just show you a
more beautiful picture conveying the
same idea on the left side here we see
one of the first patients and this upper
left most cat scan is a coronal slice
meaning we are slicing the patient up
and down which one actually slice the
patient at all this is just how the cat
scan reconstructs the picture and we see
again this ominous green circle sign so
you see on the right half of this
person's neck there's a big carotid
artery and big jugular vein as we should
all have but on the left side of its
person's neck you don't see an artery or
vein because this giant tumor that we
have circled in green is obstructing
that that vasculature the artery in the
vein if you just moved to the second
picture there it's the same thing now
we're looking at the neck but a front to
back instead of up and down the chin is
on the front is on the top here and
again you see with the green cross
hatches this the same big tumor in the
patient's neck really you can see it to
sort of budding out from the patient's
cheek and face and this patient when he
walks in the room he had a big tumors
sticking out of the side of his face but
even more scary you see it squishing the
vasculature here on the right side of
his neck you see open circles white
vasculature blood vessels that are
opened up and on the left side you see
these squished closed white vasculature
so bulky tumor in the patient's neck and
on the bottom panel here bulky tumors in
the patient's pelvis these are called
external iliac lymph node tumors and
they are you know several inches each of
themselves you know small apricots eyes
tumors here in the patient's pelvis so
he had advanced stage disease we were
treating this patient not of any of
those tumor sites but at a site that was
also a left England Oh site far away
from these tumors and we see after the
vaccination now this person has blood
vessels on both sides of his neck and
she that giant green circle has become a
small tumor with a little
in circle around it and on the
transverse imaging the far right upper
picture that we have a small crosshatch
near and almost completely opened up
vasculature with these big open white
circles on both sides of its neck now
and on the bottom right we see these
bulky pelvic tumors almost completely
regressed so that was very gratifying of
course for us for the patient for his
family as well this is showing you more
data from that same patient looking in
the patient's blood flow cytometric Lee
we see that this patient's blood was
actually full of tumors b-cells again
these lymphomas are derived from B cells
that express b cell markers like cd19
and hopefully all of us hopefully here
today have a healthy blood in which we
have more cd5 T cells than we have B
cells in our blood but this patient is
just the opposite he has many cd19 B
cells in his blood they are almost all
his cancerous B cells and again we
didn't inject the patient's blood we
just inject this one tumor lymph node at
the left inguinal site and after the
vaccination you see that those forty two
percent of his blood that's taken up by
tumor has now gone down to six point six
percent and we stop the therapy that's a
three-month time point post vaccine but
if we look three months further down the
road now the tumor cells in the blood
have continued to regress again is a
hint to us of inducing an tities
antitumor adaptive immunity this is
looking at that data b cells versus T
cells we can look at the same data in
even slow mo a more elegant way if we
look at the patients healthy B cells
versus versus his cancerous B cells so
this is really the same data looking
into the blood at these time points but
now we have on the x-axis lambda light
chain this patients lymphoma is a kappa
expressing tumor so again forty-two
percent of these cells in the blood are
is kappa expressing b cells which are as
tumor cells and we see there's a tiny
number on the bottom left here again of
healthy b cells they are lambda
expressing healthy b-cell 0.4% as we
move along during the therapy again
those tumor cells regress
but somehow the immune system is able to
distinguish the cancerous B cells from
the healthy B cells and you see those
healthy lambda positive B cells
increasing even while the cancerous B
cells are decreasing from point four
percent to one person to one-point-four
percent and even more so over time so we
hopefully have trained the immune system
here to recognize cancerous B cells and
distinguish them from healthy B cells
but you know the obvious question there
would be what is the tumor antigen that
these T cells are reacting to we don't
have the answer that question we are
actually working very aggressively to
get that answer but we don't have it yet
today we you know with the foot three
ligands therapy and these patients
probably cause many changes in the
immune repertoire so we've become more
thoughtful as since starting the trial
and now look at all of these patients
instead of with flow cytometry with math
cytometry so here is a mass cytometric
plot a spade plot looking at the patient
prior to foot 3l therapy and after flip
3l therapy and i'll just show that
transition one more time focusing on
these bottom few cell subsets like the
dendritic cell subsets very few
dendritic cells before and about a
tenfold increase in both the CD 141
dendritic cells are very rare subset and
in the CD 1c dendritic cells I give a
hint of that with flow cytometry already
but now we can look at every subset and
when we look at every subset of cells
you know the entire immune repertoire we
discover things that we would not have
even been thoughtful enough to ask about
and as an example of that here's
actually an even more honed in math
cytometry panel focused on T cell
markers and again there are so many
markers we can look at em t cells it
would be hard for any of us to pick
which combination T cell markers we
should focus on one to sort one group of
patients versus another but here if we
look at responding patients versus non
responding patients and we ask the Spade
algorithm to dis find us differences we
see here on the top panel that these
responding patients have this group of T
cells that I've circled these are cd8 T
cells that express high amounts of pd-1
lagg-3 cd38
digit so there are a reasonable number
of those cells in all of the patients
the responding patients and otherwise
but the color bark the color code here
is fold change in that T cell subset
after therapy versus before therapy so
you see these top two patients have very
little change in those T cell in that T
cell subset whereas the non responding
patients have again this was a log scale
so this is a mini fold I think it's
about a four or fivefold increase in the
pd-1 high lagg-3 high etc etc cd8
t-cells after therapy and this is
similar to something that other groups
have discovered with other types of
immunotherapy that as the cd8 t-cells
are learning how to attack the patient's
cancer that we have induction of
adaptive resistance meaning that the
cancer tries to turn off those t-cells
and these T cells start to express some
of these checkpoint molecules pd1 being
the most famous but all these others
being important as well I mean this is
not you know just academic and
interesting this is very plainly
actionable if these are the antitumor T
cells and again I haven't proven that
here but it's just a suggestion from the
precedence of prior recent publications
if those are the antitumor T cells in
there expressing a lot of pd-1 simply
adding an anti pd-1 antibody to this
therapy would be the obvious next step
and so that is our question and it just
needs last few slides I will discuss how
we plan this for the future both in the
our mouse patients and in our human
patients so this same therapy could be
improved in a few ways one way is that
instead of stimulating those dendritic
cells with a tlr agonist we have other
approaches one famous example our uncle
it advises which can be
immunostimulatory while they also kill
some cancer cells so we see here that as
we add in this Newcastle disease virus
which is a focus of some of our
collaborators here at Mount Sinai that
we have an actually profound effect by
the addition of clip3 so just cutting to
the survival curve here on the right we
see that the Newcastle disease virus
in the red curve does allow some mice to
have prolonged survival and a few mice
are cured maybe ten percent but doing
that same therapy in the context of
three login when there are more
dendritic cells in the tumor now we cure
about eighty percent of the mice and
this again is hopefully very
translatable new cast of disease virus
has already been studied in clinical
trials one of our hopes is to hopefully
begin to incorporate some three log in
with these oncolytic viruses so perhaps
they even lower hanging fruit in terms
of clinical translation is something
that's already being used every day for
our patients in the oncology clinic
which is assessing the PDL one
expression of these tumors so there's a
concept called adaptive resistance
whereby when we induce anti-tumor
immunity with cd8 t-cells their
expression of interferon gamma causes
PDL one upregulation the tumor itself so
in this same mouse model of the insight
to vaccine we see after this triple
therapy for three ligand xrt and poly IC
injection if we look at those tumors in
the third histogram we see that PDL one
expression actually does increase
probably about fivefold as compared to
baseline after the vaccine so this is
looking at all of the conditions and
only the triplet therapy causes increase
in tumor expression of PDL one so now
surprisingly we have reassessed this
maneuver using anti pd-1 antibodies
provided systemically and delightfully
we see here on the bottom these tumor
growth curves at this bottom curve on
the bottom left panel the green curve
shows that almost all of the tumors
regressed completely as compared to the
black line control or the red or blue
lines which are the inside sue vaccine
in the red line and PD 1 plus
radiotherapy in the blue line vaccine
again looking over on their bottom right
the kaplan-meier curve we see the
vaccine cures probably about forty or
fifty percent of mice but combining with
anti pd-1 antibodies and now we cure
ninety percent of animals and that was
pretty gratifying to us and also
sufficiently promising that we now have
been able to set up a deal with the
Cancer Research Institute who will fund
a clinical trial later this year of
exactly that approach combining the
insight to vaccine with anti pd-1
antibodies and again using very similar
assessment of distant regressions to
show that the therapy is working in it's
kind of nice that will also be able to
get beyond lymphoma with this trial and
also treat patients with breast cancer
head and neck cancer and maybe other
superficially accessible cancers so
combination with anti pd-1 is probably
the obvious thing in terms of clinical
translation pd-1 is by far the maybe
greatest success story in all of cancer
immunotherapy in the last 40 years or
ever but it doesn't mean that pv 1 is
necessarily the best checkpoint for us
to block so to try to get at the
question of what might be alternative or
even better checkpoints and by
checkpoint again I mean molecules that
anti-cancer cd8 t-cells expressed that
prevent their optimal anti-cancer
function we are using a novel mouse
model called the Jedi mouse the Jedi now
so i'll describe here in a second and
first i will delight in that what a
wonderful website google com is because
if you type in Jedi mouse you can find
several great pictures this was the best
of all of them so if you guys are not
familiar with the website google com I
would definitely recommend it I think we
can put a link for how to find google
com if you're not familiar with it so
the Jedi Mouse's this mouse that was
developed by our colleagues in the lab
of Brian Brown last year published here
in nature biotechnology and this mouse
generates cd8 t-cells which recognize a
peptide of the gfp molecule the green
fluorescent protein molecule so
basically these T cells can kill any
cell that is green this has a tremendous
number of opportunities for application
I'm going to skip these videos here for
the moment just to show you a later
video of how that killing occurs but
basically we can use the Jedi cd8 t-cell
to kill any green expressing cells
specifically in the class 1 h2d
background and here's a animation of
that on the bottom right we see these
green cells
melting away while the top left red
cells in the bottom left hun fluoro
protein conjugated cells are intact I'll
show that animation one more time the
right panel is just with more Jedi
t-cells the left panel with no gfp
specific t cells let me show that
animation where we see specific killing
especially here on the right at the
height ecell level of green cells
melting away and at the end of seven
days here you see there are very few
were almost no gfp-expressing tumor
cells left so we're going to take
advantage of that in the following way
and we have developed a crisper library
of 2,400 elements targeting six hundred
genes that are highly expressed in these
lymphoma cells so we have as you see
here on the Left red transduced red
flora protein transduced and from the
cells on the right green gfp transduce
lymphoma cells and just as a thought
experiment will say they all express a
checkpoint molecule will call it protein
three think of this at a PDL one like
molecule and T cells have some receptor
for that PDL one molecule at pd one like
molecule and when protein three hits
receptor of three those t-cells do not
kill as well therefore when we put this
crisper library into all of the red and
green lymphoma cells only the lymphoma
cell to get crisper number three will
lose expression of protein number three
if protein three is just a PDL one like
molecule not a survival molecule the red
cells will not be harmed at all by their
lack of three whereas the green cells
that lose three will no longer be able
to inhibit anti-cancer t-cells anti-gfp
T cells and they will be selectively
killed at a higher rate therefore
afterwards all we have to do is sort the
red and green lymphoma cells sequenced
the crispers in each and look for every
element that has a high red to green
ratio anything with a high red to green
red to green ratio is a PDL one like
molecule and that is the concept and
here's us just trying out that concept
not in the library of 2,400 elements but
just in a library of one element getting
rid of
pl1 as a poster child of these
checkpoints and what we did is we crisp
red out PDL one from red and green cells
you seen the leftmost flow plot here
we've made a sort of a 4040 10-10
mixture of left red right green and in
the bottom two panels the same but PDL
one crisper doubt so we start these
co-cultures as a 4040 10-10 mixture in
the middle panel you see when we add
anti-gfp t-cells in the top two panels
we see now the jedis are killing well
enough that instead of a 4240 ratio they
have a sixty four to nine ratio so by
the Sevenfold killing and that's in the
normal conditions but in the bottom
panel the same exact test tube in the
PDL one gene edited out version now
instead of a 64 29 ratio there's a 26
2.1 ratio so something like overall a
185 fold killing instead of seven fold
killing and so really the metric here is
that ratio of ratio is 105 185 is about
twenty seven fold better than seven so
the metric for PDL one killing is 27
meaning that without PDL one these T
cells killed 27 times better and we're
going to get that metric for every
member of this crisper library and the
library has been sort of thoughtfully
annotated here is a here is that library
of 600 elements these are things that
are highly expressed in the lymphoma
cells are somewhat immunologically
annotated meaning they may have some
role in immunomodulation and they are
specifically things that are either
surface expressed that we could target
them afterwards of an antibody or
kinases or phosphatases things that we
could block within an inhibitor and we
are looking to bring that to patients
but we're working with a few different
venture capital teams to see how we can
get that going quickly into a
translatable platform and I'll mention
one other way in which we're doing a
very similar approach using the Jedi
t-cells we call this the reverse
genetics approach as opposed to the
forward genetics approach meaning that
here instead of forcing a genotype with
a crisper instead we forced a phenotype
the phenotype of t-cell resistance
and we force that phenotype by just in
these cocultures you see by day four
we're already starting to kill most of
these green lymphoma cells on the top
left here we take those surviving cells
and we flow sort them for gfp high cells
and also class one high expressing cells
so that we don't just take the survivors
but we take the survivors that are not
cheating by just getting rid of the GFP
transgene we sort those and recall
culture them again after one generation
we don't see much difference in their
ability to resist T cells but after two
three four five generations now we start
to see some inability of t-cell to kill
these again iteratively selected
gfp-expressing cells such that on the
5th generation here we call it our 5
resistant generation five after four
days of coculture those cells are not
getting killed at all instead of 46
going down to 17 now 46 is staying at
forty six percent and that's the fifth
generation we actually have continued
this up to the eighth generation I'll
show you a video what that looks like
the top green cell here is the parental
t-cell sensitive cancer cell the bottom
yellow cell also expresses green in fact
it expresses just as much green as much
gfp as a sensitive cell but we've added
another die to it so it appears yellow
so we can tell the difference between
them and all of these other cells around
here these are almost entirely Jedi cd8
t-cells and you will see as we're going
to go to the video that and you will
you
so you saw there that that top green
sell that teeth the t-cell sensitives
green lymphoma cell on top not only was
it killed about three-quarters of the
way into that video but you saw the T
cells forming many immune synapses all
around the cell whereas on the bottom
this other cancer cell really the the T
cells almost seemed bored or sleepy
while they were surrounding it and
that's not because the cells have
different amounts of gfp or a different
amount of class one you see these
different cells have in fact the
resistance cells have even a bit more
gfp cues could because we keep selecting
for high gfp and they have the same
amount of class one and they happen to
have the same amount of PDL one so what
is the difference between these t-cell
resistant and t-cell sensitive cancers
we thought maybe it was just that the
t-cell resistant cancer somehow changes
the epitope so the t-cell do not see it
at all and you see here when T cells now
we're looking here at Jedi T cells when
they see the sensitive cancer they start
to upregulate within 96 hours activation
markers like cd69 and cd25 here in the
right panel now and we thought that
maybe when the t-cells saw the resistant
tumor that that would not happen but
it's exactly the opposite just to this
is the same as with his t-cell sensitive
tumor when the t-cell see this resistant
tumor they still start to upregulate
cd69 and cd25 by 96 hours so what's the
difference the difference is that
although they are expressing as early
activation markers when T cells see the
sensitive tumor they start to also
express cytokines interferon gamma and
TNF but when they see the resistant
tumor they get completely shut down
somehow they do not express hardly any
interfering gamma and only a very small
amount of TNF so again the early
activation is occurring but something
subsequently is turning off the ability
of these T cells to go through complete
activation and tumor recital function
has expressed by interfering gamma
production so we performed RNA seek on
the sensitive versus resistant tumor
cell lines and we have a list of
candidates of things that are increased
here on the left things that are
increased on the resistant tumor cells
we also on the right have things that
are decreased on the resistance cells
and we have moved forward
to pick perhaps our favorite candidate
so far and unfortunately can't go too
much of the details of the specifics of
each candidate but this candidate called
candidate 33 as you can see here by a
flow plot is highly expressed on the
resistant lymphoma cells it's actually a
bit bimodal but you see in about seventy
percent of the cells they have about
twenty fold more of this candidate
protein on the surface than the parental
sensitive cells and that molecule is a
transforming transmembrane molecule
involved in signaling and so over here
on the on the right-sided panel you can
see that the bottom to flow plots are
demonstrating phospho work so signaling
within those tumor cells and that marker
is something that like gates a
phosphatase intracellularly and not
surprisingly result in hypo
phosphorylation of erk so that molecule
is both highly expressed on the tumor
cells and is highly functional
decreasing downstream signaling in the
tumor cells just to show that there is
more of it and it's functional in the
tumor cells so we won't get more into
that molecule we're so validating that
this is the resistance mechanism but
both of these approaches are ways that
we hope to discover the next PDL one
like molecules expressed by cancer cells
lymphoma cells as well as other cancers
and i have to now most importantly
acknowledged all the people that did
this work to members of my lab my many
collaborators here at the Mount Sinai
School of Medicine and very importantly
our core facilities especially our
immune monitoring Corps led by soon g
commercial tanabe Bremen that really
have a veritably plug-in play models
head up so we can get mass cytometry
site off experiments done both on our
patient samples and on our animal
samples from the lab very quickly and I
have to really congratulate them because
they were just awarded a grant to get a
second site off machine that's how busy
our first sight off has been that the
throughput is just about maxed out now
we were luckily too lucky to have an
opportunity now to get a second one as
well as a tissue side top machine which
is coming later on this year as well and
of course we have to think the
people that helped fund the research and
we sometimes don't emphasize this enough
that we have to thank the patients that
are involved in these clinical trials
because they are really going very well
out of their way to both you know look
into a novel therapy that may be
effective or might not be but also to go
along with all of the extra requirements
involved in us getting the samples
needed so that we can try to learn
something from these clinical trials and
hopefully I've expressed some of that
learning here for you today and I'll be
happy to take any questions excellent
presentations dr. foulon and dr. Brody
thanks for bringing that information to
us before we get started with all your
questions here's a quick reminder about
how to reach just assumes can be sent
via the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
get you as many as we can our first
question is do you have those GF ta20
tumor cells commercially available and
this is for dr. Brody a great question
you guys can hear me I think gfp floral
protein transduced 820 cells are not
commercially available they're fairly
easy to make and if somebody wants to
contact me we could probably figure
something else good question great
another one for you what did math
cytometry add your analyses that flow
cytometry would not have it's a great
question I actually try to scan these
flies over just slide number 27 that I
think maybe you're one great example of
an answer I mean here we are looking at
a t-cell focused a cd8 t-cell focused
method commentary panel where we have
many markers i think 434 markers and we
of course never be able to fit all of
those into a flow cytometry panel and
wouldn't if we had used four different
panels not known which markers to
associate together we may not have had
pd1 lagg-3 cd38 and pinned it all
together but with those markers all
together we found this particular
subpopulation of what we believe are
highly exhausted possibly anti-cancer
t-cells that increase in the non
responding patients and stay
the same and responding patients don't
increase in those patients so we can go
back by flow cytometry now you know we
think the flow cytometry is not dead we
can go back and use these service
marketers to sort these populations and
test them functional and see if they
really are exhausted cells and of course
you know this can guide the next round
of trials which will be to add anti pd-1
antibodies and maybe in the future
multiple antibodies as we move forward
that's a good question as well and for
you again how do you use immune
monitoring data and our mouse study data
to make decisions about immunotherapy
choices that's a great question and a
difficult one because you know that is
really the problem of the field of
immunology we have what's a good problem
to have we have too many choices but the
problem therefore is we don't know how
to combine all the possible choices we
have you know just to pick a group of
molecules monoclonal antibodies against
ox40 lagg-3 10-3 of course pd-1 and
ctla-4 and easily a dozen others plus
small molecule kinase inhibitors i Doan
hitters and so forth in the clinic
what's the right combination of these
things we really don't know and
unfortunately it's driven a lot by sort
of a separate agenda you know industry
pharma and biotech agendas of what they
happen to have on their shelves which is
okay but not the ideal way to drive
combinatorial strategies so we really
need to be looking in the trials that we
do you have a lot of lip service to
biomarker studies but we really need to
be obtaining you know tumor samples
during therapy to see what is the state
of the t-cells ideally as we're able to
the state of the antitumor t cells as
opposed to the rest of the rest of the
nonspecific t-cell to see what we could
do to be helping those t-cells kill
cancer more effectively so we can learn
some of that from really in-depth immune
monitoring of our ongoing clinical
trials but it really has to be done it
has to cry out be prioritized when we
write up those clinical trial protocols
and dr bowie distance for you did you
test different types of pd-1 monoclonal
antibodies other than Tamra when you
considered addition of pd-1 blockade to
your insight to vaccines approach I
that's an interesting question I'll tell
you quite honestly we think the majority
of pd-1 and ppl one antibodies that are
either fda-approved or in the clinic are
probably more similar than different so
those decisions probably get made more
at a practical level of which industry
collaborators are looking for this type
of collaboration so yeah we are open to
Pemberley Zeb Navarro Mabbutt as ilysm
ab on all of the others that are
probably be FDA approved soon and in
different files we use different quite
literally we have different trials some
with Nevada maps done with chem bro some
with a tezo so we are open to all this
and dr. Brody can be activated antitumor
cd8 t-cell be found in patient
peripheral blood after treatment they
definitely can be it may not be the best
place to find them and depending on the
timing and what the therapy is so for
example after Anna any anti pd-1 therapy
we think the chances are much higher
because we sometimes find them in the
peripheral blood after anti pd-1 therapy
and then we go back and sometimes look
with tetra MERS to see actually if there
was a small proportion even prior to
therapy and they're frequently is but
it's a very small number and it's hard
to find the signal versus the noise so
yes we can find in the peripheral blood
again we sometimes they might be in the
blood and that may not Carly with
anti-cancer effect if the job of course
of those t-cells is to get to the tumor
site just generating them peripheral II
might not be enough to induce antitumor
effect we need to see them at the tumor
as well we can find them in the blood
which is obviously is much more
accessible dr. Brody how do you decide
the frequency of tissue monitoring post
therapy now there's some more practical
question as well some of these therapies
that I talked about inside to
vaccinations rely on our ability to
access the tumors literally with a
syringe in a needle so they are
superficial tumors things like lymphoma
breast cancer head and neck cancer and
therefore we can do you know fine needle
aspirate sore core biopsy of these it's
not that fun for patients and we do
these every couple of weeks and patients
tolerate that if we did them every day
patients would not tolerate that and
similarly with peripheral blood sampling
if we do this every week or two patients
tolerate that much more than that is
difficult not just because patients
don't like getting poked with needles
but because these patients live
somewhere between 30 minutes and and 12
hours away some of these patients are
traveling across country to be part of
these trials so it's just not practical
to do too much monitoring of course the
you know the expense and the resources
involved or practical concern as well
but we try to do weekly monitoring in
the near term after the start and during
therapies so we have a sense of how they
are changing the immune repertoire
sorry about that I just had my speaker
and if I'm going to season my speaker we
take the last question so dr. Brody I
think we have time for one more question
the question is slit three ligon is
known to expand many other myeloid cell
types including monocytes and
myeloid-derived suppressor cells how
would you overcome the possibility of
potentially inducing some of these other
cell types yeah it's a great question
and while you're asking it I'll just
flip back to these slides number 25 and
26 this is prior to flip three therapy
have site off spate analysis and here
too after fluttery therapy and the
peripheral blood of one of our patients
and as the questioner asks we do see
these dendritic cells populations
increasing many folds but we do see
these other shifts these Bluegreen
changes in the will just generally call
a my load compartment some of them are
cd14 monocyte some of them or other
types of myeloid cells and some of those
could be NDSCS really i think in terms
of MDS CS another related
differentiation factor gm-csf is the
most famous for inducing MDS CS but as
possible to split 3l could also induce
some tolerogenic myeloid cells you know
one way we approach this is we
definitely do not think slit three
ligands era p would be a good
monotherapy quite honestly i think it
would be more tolerant genic and
immunogenic so an important part of our
approach here is that we need to
activate those myeloid cells after the
recruited and that's with the
application or intratumoral
administration of toll-like receptor
agonist be about Polly I CLC like in
this trial or other approaches a other
tlr agonist other sting agonist that
we're using in the clinic now and those
can sometimes also even that convert MDS
cs2 more functional my m1 type
macrophages or other probably helpful
inflammatory myeloid cells instead of
tolerogenic myeloid cells so I think the
answer is a these cell recruiting
factors are not as
Vallone therapy we need my lord cell
activating factors can currently be a
tlr agonist sting agonist or even
perhaps oncolytic viruses that's a great
question thank you I'd like to thank the
audience for all their great questions
and if we didn't get yours we will
follow up you via email but also like to
once again thank dr. Michelle Poulin and
dr. Joshua Brody for their presentations
do you have any final comments I just
like to thank everyone for the great
opportunity of sharing some of our work
thank you I also like to thank our
sponsor fluidigm for making it possible
to bring this presentation to you
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through october
eleventh 2017 you'll receive an email
from us alerting the awareness available
on demand and posted on labrum you are
welcome to forward this announcement to
any colleagues who weren't able to join
in today thanks for logging on and
participating in today's broadcast we'll
see you next time